[Music]  you sound great  yeah right what you told me you weren't  feeling it you were in it  we don't need to put them all out  [Music]  uh  your hearing is deteriorating rapidly  we'll come back till then lou we just  keep going okay no  lou let's play tomorrow and see what  it's like okay i'm gonna be like a click  track you can play to me  [Music]  i can't hear you do you understand me i  can't  i found a place i think it's important  that you stay here with us right now  reuben  we're looking for a solution to to this  not this i need you to wait for me  okay you're ready for me losing my part  you're it for me  okay you gotta wait for me  [Music]  [Music]  i'm trying to save my life reuben  the world does keep moving it can be a  damn cruel place  but those moments of stillness  [Music]  when this  [Music]  crappy mundane  [Music]  suddenly becomes radiant and magnificent  [Music]  all the fear is gone  that place  will never abandon you  [Music]  you